[Musique]
il y a des choses qui ne changeront
jamais et ça c'est plutôt rassurant pour
le reste on est quelques degrés au
dessus des précautions d'usagé en crèche
les agents doivent prendre leur
température chez elle également avant
d'arriver et les enfants on demande aux
parents qu'ils soient pris à la maison
et si c'est pas pris par les parents ou
s'ils doutent
on prend la température à la crèche si
thermomètre masqué gel sont devenus les
nouveaux outils de travail de la petite
enfance c'est bien sûr parce qu'on ne
joue pas avec la santé
mais c'est aussi pour tranquilliser les
parents et faire revenir les enfants
1400 accueillis sur l'année dans les 15
crèches de la ville comme je vois ici le
congo sont très strictes aux nouveaux de
sony terre de boue je suis content les
protocoles ont déjà été mis en place
avant les vacances scolaires donc voila
tout à fait rassuré j'ai habitude de la
crèche donc il n'y a aucun souci de ce
côté là elle est en sécurité et moi je
suis tranquille
il n'en demeure pas moins comme un léger
flou le guide ministériel censé valider
les bonnes pratiques n'est pas encore
sorti quant à la rubrique qu'est ce
qu'on fait si quelqu'un tombe malade
elle reste à écrire
nous n'aurons pas de protocole établi
sur ce quoi parce que cela relève des
missions de l'état à travers l' agence
régionale de santé
donc si un cas est détecté ce sera
immédiatement
dialoguer pris en charge par l' agence
régionale de santé avec madame la maire
avec la maire adjointe à l'éducation a
causé un espace dédié à la petite
enfance et donc les solutions seront
trouvées lesquels mystère mais les
directives sont attendus avant mardi
quand le gros des troupes fera son
entrée dans la cour des grands